welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Anthony Mason and Tony
to copal a young woman who encouraged
her friend to kill himself in a series
of text messages is out of jail today
Michelle Carter was released more than
three months early
she served nearly a year of her 15-month
sentence she was convicted of
involuntary manslaughter in 2017 three
years after 18 year-old Conrad Roy died
by suicide 48 hours correspondent Erin
Moriarty has been following this case
and joins us at the table I remember
this story a lot of intense feelings
here why was she released so early well
simply put good morning but simply put
she was released yesterday on good
behavior she was incarcerated after a
judge determined that she was criminally
responsible for Conrad Roy suicide her
case may be over but the debate about
whether words alone can be lethal
weapons is not she was Michelle Carter
was released early from the Bristol
County House of Corrections in Dartmouth
Massachusetts the county sheriff said
Carter had accrued enough goodtime
credits after participating in jail
programs
Carter's release may end her nearly
three-year battle to have the conviction
overturned in 2017 Carter was held
responsible for the death of Conrad Roy
Roy died in his truck of carbon monoxide
poisoning in a Kmart parking lot three
years earlier investigators found
hundreds of texts from Carter to Roy
urging him to end his life
one of her techs read you're ready and
prepared all you have to do is turn the
generator on and you'll be free and
happy no more pushing it off no more
waiting
we spoke to Conrad's mom Lynn Roy for 48
hours there was one point where he
actually got out of the truck and
changed his mind yeah he was scared and
she told him to go back in the truck yes
Carter argued that her conviction based
on her words alone violated her First
Amendment right to free speech
her appeal ended earlier this month when
the US Supreme Court declined to hear it
lynn roy issued a statement after
Carter's release which reads in part for
my family we have reached closure I will
continue to honor my son and to find
ways to help others who may be
experiencing what I have experienced she
and Roy's sisters spoke about that pain
it still hurts just as much as it didn't
fan doesn't I will live with this
forever
the pain Michelle Carter is out but now
she has a criminal record and she will
be on probation for the next two and a
half years you know it's interesting
when I said that debate will continue
the debate is continuing at this table
right here about the Roy family this is
very very painful and this young woman
has never spoken about this no she
hasn't or anyone or her family reached
out but this case is really gonna have a
big impact is it over the Supreme Court
and has now rejected here it has and
unless she violates probation I think
her case is pretty much over but the
thing is it's had an impact because we
now know what coercive suicide is
Conrad's mother Lynne is really hoping
that Massachusetts will pass Conrad's
law which will make coercive suicide
against the law punishable up to five
years if someone has that kind of
emotional pain I think pretty very
simply you help them get help yes and
you were saying Michelle Gard had never
showed remorse no but also there was a
benefit that she got the evidence
indicated that she tried to cover up so
she knew what she did was wrong and that
she pushed him at least from the
evidence because she wanted sympathy and
attention from friends high school being
high school yeah and from the time
you're a little kid we're all taught
words are very powerful yeah they are
heart
thank you very much every speech aside
Erin thank you very much